And it's really tragic.
And as Chomsky says, let's be activists for
stuff once Biden wins.
But if Biden doesn't win, our activism goes
nowhere.
There's no chance of anything if Trump wins.
And that's the key point that Chomsky is making
here.
Let's be united around it.
This is not a debate about blue, no matter
who.
I don't even know who's seriously saying that
there's any sort of validity to Blue, no matter
who.
It's Trump and Biden.
Biden happens to be the Democratic candidate.
Trump happens to be the Republican candidate.
We've evaluated two options and picked the
better.
One, making this a debate about the concept
of voting for the Democrat.
Whoever they are, is ridiculous.
We're 21 days out and it's Biden versus Trump.
It's not blue no matter who are blue.
If this or blue, is that really well done
by Noam Chomsky?
Let's come together around it.
Yesterday was day two of Amy CONI Barrett's
confirmation hearings to the Supreme Court.
Barrett is Donald Trump's nominee to replace
the late, great Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
Barrett couldn't possibly come from a more
different philosophy than Ginsburg.
Barrett is a religious Christian, a member
of a cult named the People of Praise, who
said Antonin Scalia was the most in line with
her judicial philosophy.
Day two of the confirmation hearings truly
a clinic in obfuscation and deception.
And what's stunning about yesterday's second
day of hearings is that I don't think Amy
CONI Barrett actually said anything directly
about her philosophy.
Her answers were either saying nothing and
explaining why she'll be saying nothing or
telegraphing her positions in a coy and deceptive
way while leaving herself complete latitude
to do anything in the future.
And all sorts of senators taking a shot at
it, just a pathetic lack of openness.
Sometimes it was almost comical.
And I say almost comical because then you
remember, wait, she might be influencing the
top level judiciary of the country for decades
when you're about to laugh.
You remember that and you stop laughing.
So let's look at some examples.
There is speculation that Donald Trump will
dispute the election.
If he does, it could reach the Supreme Court.
So Chris Coons, Democratic senator, asked
Barrett whether she'd recuse herself from
any cases related to this election since it
would be an obvious conflict, having to adjudicate
an election in which the guy who nominated
you is a candidate.
But she won't.
She won't recuse herself.
But I think the groveled in the court, the
core issue in recusal is that any judge or
justice should recuse themselves from a case
in which their impartiality might reasonably
be questioned.
Given what President Trump said, given the
rushed context of this confirmation, will
you commit to recusing herself from any case
arising from a dispute in the presidential
election results three weeks from now?
Senator Coons, thank you for giving me the
opportunity to clarify this, because I want
to be very clear for the record and to all
members of this committee that no matter what
anyone else may think or expect, I have not
committed to anyone or so much has signaled.
I've never even written.
I've been in a couple of opinions in the 7th
Circuit that has been around the edges of
election law.
But I haven't even written anything that I
would think anybody could reasonably say.
This is how she might resolve an election
dispute.
So she does not commit to that.
And why would she?
I mean, there's been no consequences to anything
any of Donald Trump's cronies have done.
Why would she recuse herself?
No way.
No surprise at all.
Then it goes to Corey Booker, Democratic senator
from New Jersey, who asks about the importance
of presidents committing to a peaceful transfer
of power, something that presidents should
commit themselves to generally.
And she won't answer that.
Corey Booker presses her and she still won't
do it.
Yes.
To this time.
Here's another one.
Do you believe that every president should
make a commitment unequivocally and resolutely
to the peaceful transfer of power?
Well, Senator, that seems to me to be pulling
in a little bit into this question of whether
the president has said that he would not peacefully
leave office.
And so to the extent that this is a political
controversy right now, as a judge, I want
to stay out of it and I don't want to express
a view on.
So, Judge.
I appreciate you.
What you've said about respecting our founding
fathers, about originalism.
It's remarkable that we're in a place right
now that this is becoming a question and a
topic.
But I'm asking you, in light of our founding
fathers aloud of our traditions, in light,
that everyone who serves in that office has
sworn an oath with a, quote, swear to preserve
and protect and defend the Constitution, the
United States.
I'm just asking you.
Should a president commit themselves like
our our founding fathers, I think, have a
clear intention, like the grace that George
Washington showed to the peaceful transfer
of power.
Is that something that presidents should be
able to do?
Well, one of the beauties of America from
the beginning of the republic is that we have
had peaceful transfers of power and that disappointed
voters have accepted the new leaders that
come into office.
And that's not true in every country.
And I think it is part of the genius of our
Constitution.
Did you see what she did there when asked
about whether presidents should commit to
peaceful transfers of power?
She says the great thing about the U.S. is
we've always had peaceful transfers of power,
which, of course, ignores that we've never
had a president like Trump who won't actually
commit to one.
But she leaves that out conveniently.
Really interesting moment when it was Senator
Kamala Harris, his turn.
Kamala asks whether Barrett is aware that
Donald Trump has made comments about striking
down the Affordable Care Act and is pursuing
lawsuits to strike down the Affordable Care
Act.
And Barrett says she hasn't heard of them.
But Harris was prepared.
And Harris says, well, while you were talking
to people getting ready for these hearings,
certainly the topic must have come up right.
And this puts Barrett into a pretzel where
she has to admit.
Well, yeah, I was told it might come up, but
not in the context of Trump pledging to eliminate
and suing to eliminate the ACA doesn't pass
the sniff test.
Let's take a look here.
I asked you earlier today, but did not receive
an answer prior to your nomination.
Were you aware of President Trump's statements
committing to nominate judges who will strike
down the Affordable Care Act?
I appreciate.
Yes or no answer, please.
Well, a senator has said wouldn't it be very,
very careful?
I'm under oath.
I as I'm sitting here, I don't recall seeing
those statements.
But if let's say I don't recall seeing or
hearing loss statements, but I don't really
know what context they were in.
So I guess I can't really definitively give
you a yes or no answer.
What I would like to say is I don't recall
hearing about or seeing such statements.
Well, I imagine you were surrounded by a team
of folks that helped prepare you for this
nomination hearing.
I have had.
Yeah.
But let me finish, if you don't mind.
I'm sorry.
Did they inform you of the president's statements
and that this might be a question that was
presented to during the course of this hearing?
When I had my calls with senators, it came
up many of many of the Democratic senators
wanted to know about the Affordable Care Act.
And to satisfy themselves that I had not made
any pre commitments to the president about
it.
And so you then became aware of the president's
statement, is that correct?
Let's see.
Senator Harris, in the context of these conversations,
I honestly can't remember whether senators
framed the questions in the context of President
Trump's comments.
Perhaps so.
I think from my perspective, the most important
thing is to say that I have never made a commitment.
I've never been asked to make a commitment.
And I hope that the committee would trust
in my integrity.
So understand that, Barrett says, well, the
Affordable Care Act did come up with multiple
senators, but not in the context of what Trump
said she wants us to believe.
She had multiple conversations about the Affordable
Care Act without it ever being mentioned that
Trump has been on a four year rampage, including
lawsuits to get rid of the Affordable Care
Act.
Completely not believable.
Now, as a brief interlude, check out this
hard hitting question from Republican Senator
Ben Sasse.
Tell us about the Scalia Ginsburg friendship
and the impact that it made on you.
Really tough stuff, right?
So that was that was a Republican interlude.
Now back to real questions in this next one,
Senator Dianne Feinstein Laine's lays out
a question, which is you say you were like
Scalia.
Scalia didn't think gay people should get
married, could get married legally.
What do you think?
Cases.
Now, you said in your acceptance speech for
this nomination that Justice Scalia's philosophy
is your philosophy.
Do you agree with this particular point of
Justice Scalia's view that the U.S. Constitution
does not afford gay people the fundamental
right to marry?
Senator Feinstein, as I said to Senator Graham
at the outset, if I were confirmed, you would
be getting Justice Berrett, not Justice Scalia.
So I don't think that anybody should assume
that just because Justice Scalia decided decision
a certain way that I went to.
But I'm not going to express a view on whether
I agree or disagree with Justice Scalia for
the same reasons that I've been giving out.
Justice Ginsburg, with her characteristic
pithiness, used this way to describe how a
nominee should comport herself at a hearing.
So that's a game Barrett plays.
She is smart where she will cite Ruth Bader
Ginsburg in some innocuous way to avoid answering
a real question.
And Feinstein tries again on Roe v. Wade,
doesn't get any further with it.
So on something that is really a major cause
with major affect on over half of the population
of this country who are women.
After all, it's it's distressing not to get
a straight answer.
So let me try again.
Do you agree with Justice Scalia's view that
Roe was wrongly decided?
Senator, I completely understand why you are
asking the question.
But again, I can't pre comment or say, yes,
I'm going in with some agenda because I'm
not.
I don't have any agenda.
I have no agenda to try to overrule Casey.
I have an agenda to stick to the rule of law
and decide cases as they come.
They often use this framing to avoid answering.
I'll decide cases as they as they come up
speculating about past decisions.
You know, you never get any actual answer
out of them.
And then lastly, from yesterday, there's more.
But these are some highlights.
Here's Amy Klobuchar asking very simply, do
you agree it's illegal to intimidate voters
at the polls?
And Barrett says it's a hypothetical.
It's not.
It's simply a question about the law.
Judge Barron, under federal law.
Is it illegal to intimidate voters at the
polls?
Senator Clubbish, I can't characterize the
facts in a hypothetical situation, and I can't
apply the law to a hypothetical set of facts.
I can only decide cases as they come to me,
litigated by parties on a full record after
fully engaging precedent, talking to colleagues,
writing an opinion.
And so I can't answer questions like, well,
I'll make I'll make it easier.
18 USC five nine four outlaws.
Anyone who intimidates, threatens, coerces
or attempts to intimidate, threaten or curse
any other person for the purpose of interfering
with the right of such other person to vote.
This is a law that has been on the books for
decades.
So no answer there either.
So what did we learn yesterday?
We learned quite simply that Amy CONI Barrett
is really slippery and we'll say nothing.
And Republicans will come out of these hearings
say they were very pleased with Amy CONI Barrett's
performance.
Let's go and vote her in.
In all likelihood, it's what will happen.
Let me know what you thought about yesterday's
hearings.
I'm on Twitter at
David Pakman.